that puts it to rest at at least as to
the question of whether or not it's
still garoppolo's job when he's healthy
when he's healthy there's always a
chance that someone's playing the 100
game and if the other guy catches fire
like colin kaepernick in 2012 when alex
smith had a concussion right and i'm
gonna go all the way back to randy
moss's rookie year brad johnson breaks a
leg week two randall cunningham comes in
and he has this career rebirth and danny
green eventually says brad johnson's a
quarterback when he's 100 percent he was
just never 100
again right never it should have been
maybe 100 in the second half of the nfc
championship game that's a different
story altogether but but that's the way
you do it now i don't suspect it's going
to happen chris i think jimmy garoppolo
is better than nick mullins the question
is can garoppolo do enough this year
that he's still the guy in 2021 that was
the big question based upon what we saw
week one and that's going to be the
question when he's back playing against
some of these nfc west not nfc east
teams yeah no it's a fair question i i
mean i'm i'm with you there i think this
is like kind of a another year of like
evaluating jimmy g and his growth and
can this be the year he solidifies
himself as like okay
you are the guy here we're not gonna
even talk about it anymore even if tom
brady calls in the offseason we won't
flirt with him or anything you're the
guy going forward that's that's where
they are here and jimmy garoppolo like
you said is is a better player than nick
mullins there's no doubt nick mullens
did a fine job last week he did make
some careless throws too that could have
easily been intercepted that hit giants
players right in the chest
he can't deliver the ball as quickly
garoppolo has a very quick release he
can flick it almost in very awkward
positions nick mullins is a more a
little more slow and deliberate with the
way he does his things and he's just not
up to the caliber a player garoppolo is
but certainly still a fine player and
you could see with shanahan's offensive
genius and even just a fine quarterback
as we saw when jimmy garoppolo got hurt
and before he got there they could put
up points and numbers it's just about
could they win those games and that's
where jimmy g has really helped them
he's been clutching some big moments to
help them win games that they were not
winning before he got there and i know
the super bowl didn't work out but there
was a plenty other games last year
during the regular season where he came
through for them
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports